i just want to hear your reaction to
what was probably the biggest moment in
hip-hop this past year was your versus
with uh with gucci i mean i think it was
the biggest one ever
obviously and probably the most watched
so for me it's just like you know when
it's real it's real
you know we all the culture atlanta is
the coaches for everybody to come back
in magic city which is one of my
legendary spots on that very stage
it was definitely a legendary night in
these atl streets for sure
[Music]
yo what up doe gq it's your boy jeezy
these are my essentials
let's get into it
now one thing that i've learned in my
humble beginnings in my life is the
people that i
really respect they just have a few
things they need so i'm a simple guy
you know i'm a simple person so first
and foremost
you know got to keep the keys to the
whip so i can get out the house
and get in traffic and shake and move so
you got to do that
so you can't leave without having these
so keep you some keys
get you some keys if you got no keys
you should have some these are the keys
to my rolls royce
i do have a lot of cars but you know
most of the time i just keep it simple
all my fleet is white i happen to like
white cars you know
man it goes with it goes with who i am
but
my thing is about class i just they keep
things clean no rim
factory um you know just classy you know
like myself so uh yeah that's what i do
on the weekdays you see me on a friday
though it gets busy
so rolls-royce keys right here drop the
top in traffic
right here on my wrist gotta know the
time
got ahead at rolly you know what i mean
playing jane scott dweller
i do own a lot of watches but i try to
keep it plain as possible because
you know i just feel like that's more
powerful for me when you walk around
and you look like it and you feel good
and you can actually tell the time what
you watch
um i think that that that shows what
type of person you are you know with it
without the stone so
i like to do the plain jane so gotta
have that rollie
how do you feel cheesy about the new
wave a lot of these young guys getting
the uh the resharp mill
how do i feel about it i mean i i
respect it you know you got to think
you know when i came in the game i had
every piece of jury you could name
every watch there was with diamonds in
it so i respect we all got to go through
that
phase it's a phase you know what i mean
and it's like you get to your money
that's how you want to spend it i
respect it
um you know just for me it's just like a
lot of places that i go
it doesn't require that but when i do
pop out and i need that i got a few of
those too
you know what i mean but i like to do
the playing j you know what i mean
sometimes just keep it real clean classy
as i say
um classy and and that's what i'm about
so shout outs out to them if they you
know they want to rock the
right the iced out richard mule or
whatever they want to do man that's
state paper and that's how they want to
spin it
can't leave home without my trusted
computer i call this my computer right
here
got a picture of me and my mom's on the
cover right there you know when i was a
young
rp mom we love you um but this is like
you know
coming up i wasn't like a computer head
so i didn't i didn't
like dealing with digits and gadgets but
this can this this phone is like my
computer i can run all my companies from
this phone i can make sure my peoples
are straight i can uh send email
text what have you see what's going on
in the world so it's like one of the
first things i gotta have when i get up
i don't look at it in the morning first
because i give myself time to reset but
i can't leave outside the house without
this this is a big essential because
without this
i can't connect with nobody and then if
i can't connect nobody they can't
connect with me so i got a lot of things
going on
so this helps this is my computer that's
what i call it my phone so that's second
gotta have to smell good you know some a
little adventist this is my everyday
you know i'm a bakla rock guy uh i do a
little
uh creed every now and then this is like
my everyday just throw on and make sure
i'm fresh
and walk out the house and um you know
i'm smelling good you got to feel good
look good it smell good
so this is like essential for me gotta
have this
smells like snowman
[Music]
i can't leave without my wallet got my
driver's license in it
all my credit cards you know i'm a cash
you know i love throwing cash in the
duffel bags and all that
but what i did learn over time is it's a
lot easier so for me
when i pull up and just flash the cards
it makes it easy i'm
to have a whole bunch of cash in my
pockets unless that's something i really
want to do
but you can't leave out the house
without this and i find myself uh more
and more daily like
you know really you know really
appreciating having credit cards instead
of walking around with a pocket full of
cash
jesus you mentioned bitcoin do you ever
foresee a world in which you'll be like
just
trading bitcoin i hope not i hope not i
mean i get it
you know we we with it but it's like you
know when you want to grab a pocket full
of cash you got to have that you know
you want to break out your black card is
always good
um again you know i'm not like a crazy
computer guy so i wouldn't want to get
on
line to uh buy a home or to buy a car to
buy some real estate
uh using bitcoin i'm quite sure i can
hit my and he can do that
but um i don't know how to see how to
see y'all to see how it works out for me
you know what i mean
[Music]
it's the finest fuel right here um water
you got to stay hydrated um
definitely one of my companies one of my
businesses but i truly believe in the
brand
and for me it's a big part of who i am
staying hydrated
and staying charged up and this helped
us so so
you know you got to have if you don't
got something defined for you get some
defies for you but
however whatever you drinking makes you
stay hydrated that's real like you can't
your body is it's your
vehicle if you're not hydrated and you
ain't you know at the top of your game
you can't do much out here so shouts out
to that gotta stay hydrated
and like i said i'm a simple guy you
know i like to grind hard
then you know after you get it get done
grinding out a whole week of
getting to it and you gotta celebrate
there's nothing better than right here
but this nod
vsap vs op cognac
fine cognac that is you know when i sit
down smoke muscle guards like a real
ball should
i have to just crack a bottle of this
put it on one cube of ice
sit back and i wish i brought my
favorite cigars for me i don't have but
um this is what i do this is my friday
evening it's on
you know just just on the balls tip so
now vodka
not fine cognac y'all make sure y'all
get some of that
yeah real talk you know i got to have my
band
on my wedding band that it means a lot
to me you know i got a few of them
playing jane i got some iced out ones
but
that's to go outside the house you know
what i mean do my thing but you know
when it's solid it's solid so you know
i'm gonna rep that well
just a loyal guy
i got to have the all black fitted
no matter what i do how i do it
that's just who i am you know what i
mean i i feel uncomfortable when i'm
outside the house
and i don't have a blackfield at home or
fitted for that matter so
this is a part of me i can't see
properly if i don't have them
it's my sunglasses you know what i'm
saying
i'm never leaving the house
without my shades i cannot i will not i
won't do it
and if you ever see me out in traffic
and i ain't got them on then
today might not be my day you know what
i mean cause that's how i'm rolling no
matter what i keep my shades on
it just keep me cool calm and collect
and it can be dark outside
i'm still have them all know that these
are details and
i own hundreds of shades um but for me
it's just my my shades predict my mood
like if i'm feeling
cheat up i'm gonna throw some ray bans
you know what i'm saying i'm feeling you
know really
saucy i might throw some cardigans you
know what i mean if i'm feeling like
it's gonna be one of those days i might
throw some ferragamos
um and freight like a lot of people
shoot heads and snicker heads
to me for me is the shades you know your
shade game got to be
of the part if i'm on vacation i might
have the you know
the gucci frames on with the with the
green tits or whatever
but you know it just depends on where
i'm at and how i'm feeling
so if you see me you see my shades on
you can tell my mood all day
you know what it is like i told you man
i'm a simple guy thank you guys for
watching
uh maybe next time you see me i had 10
different ones you never know
salute gq y'all know what it is big snow
let's get it